well a number of protests have now taken
place in Chinese cities there have been
demonstrations in arumchi and xinjiang
Province where 10 people died in an
apartment fire reportedly because
Emergency Services there were hindered
by covid lockdown procedures well
Gatherings have also taken place across
Beijing including in the city's one of
its biggest universities where people
sang the national anthem in solidarity
protests last night in Wuhan as well
where coronavirus first broke out was
reported anyway reports of people
pushing down police barricades and
police have used pepper spray on
demonstrators in Shanghai people have
been detained by police and protesters
were taken away in Vans and buses today
from there our Asia correspondent Helen
Ann Smith has the latest
put my makeup broke the morning after
something momentous Shanghai felt like a
totally different City
the protesters gone police replaced them
around the hot spots barriers went up
and so did the tension
the message here felt abundantly clear
more would not be stood for
just a bit further up here is the
crossroads where the protests have been
focused and the roads are open but there
are these big barricades that have been
put up
if last night things were angry and
emotional today they just feel
incredibly tense
such was the police presence it was hard
to film anything here but agitation was
in the air
and we captured this moment on a phone
his crime unclear lingering too long
perhaps
as night fell there was a sense the
heavy-handedness was working people
didn't gather in large groups as before
but there was a Defiance here still in a
much quieter form a lone sunflower left
on a Bollard and this man who positioned
himself right next to police and sat
watching even this is incredibly Brave
he gave his name only as Rey away from
their glare he told us why he came I
really think that's the garmin's policy
against the kovitz it's like two strict
and it's violating our rights as a
common human do you think people are
afraid are you afraid I'm Not Afraid
speaking for myself
um
and yes there are people who are afraid
because I do see that
there are videos of policemen crushing
people and
[Music]
I know what happened next
it's an all too predictable fate
officers swept in protesters swept up we
saw Ray being questioned were unsure
what happened next
elsewhere too after multiple cities saw
action last night this small disturbance
in nearby Hangzhou one of the only
things to break through
foreign
but the underlying grievance has not
gone away zero covered exhaustion images
of the rest of the world in packed World
Cup stadiums haven't helped shots of
unmasked fans now being actively
replaced obscured by the senses but what
happened here has still made history it
has still been extraordinary there's a
sense voices might be quiet for now but
not forever Helena Smith Sky News in
Shanghai